all right guys bang-bang
a very special guest today I think that
she is incredibly well known in certain
circles and then incredibly unknown in
other circles but she's got an
incredible story so cat thank you so
much for doing this yeah thanks for
having me all right we're gonna spend
some time on your backstory because it
is probably one of the best business
stories that I've heard where did you
grow up and kind of what did you do
before let's say the age of 15 years old
so grew up in Jacksonville Florida my
family was pretty poor on both sides of
the family with the exception of my
family my dad so my dad's side the
family all truckers Junkers factory
workers mom's side of the family same
thing and yet my dad had a white-collar
job so we had a house a car at a
playhouse from the outside everything
looked pretty amazing especially
compared to the rest of our family
but by the age of nine I'm the oldest of
three girls two younger sisters so I was
nine they were six and three my mom came
to me and said that's it I'm done we're
leaving and we were leaving my dad he
was an alcoholic and a good man but a
terrible husband and father and so we
left and my mom fed us on a food budget
of $10 a week for three years she worked
three jobs and a lot of what transpired
up to that point of being 15 was being a
father figure at home working all the
local jobs that I could before I started
like actual jobs at the age of 15 so at
some point I think you were what 17 18
years old you go and you get a job at
Hooters and when people hear that I
think it's probably a lot of people's
reactions like why did you do that right
and so that back context is an important
piece of it but like why did you go to
get the job at Hooters starting out as a
waitress there yeah you know I it was my
third job I worked I clean gym equipment
I worked in a mall and sold clothes
and then as soon as I turned 17 I
applied to be a hostess at Hooters and
you know I was in high school and people
work one out of every two Americans I
think their first job or one of their
first jobs as in hospitality so going to
work in a restaurant as a hostess as a
high school students pretty typical
what's unique about it is that it's
Hooters but Hooters had been in
Jacksonville for almost a decade at that
point over a decade it wasn't unique it
was just another restaurant and it
looked like a ton of fun and so I just
applied to be a hostess I was recruited
at the place where I was selling clothes
in the mall by some woman who had a
business card and she was a Hooters
recruiter and so she came he was like
you have you know you have great
customer service skills you have the
look that we look for we'd love for you
to come and apply and so I was like oh
dope that sounds awesome so I went
applied I became a hostess and then when
I turned 18 I was able to rock the
orange shorts because you have to be 18
to serve alcohol and it's a restaurant
that served alcohol about 20% of the
sales at the time we're alcohol so it
was more of a restaurant than a bar but
I was a waitress and that was all before
I graduated high school okay and so when
you graduate high school you basically
go on this like wild ride from what I
understand from being a waitress to
eventually you're opening up lots of
stores around the world at a young age
for Hooters or in kind of an executive
type role how do we get from you working
at one single Jacksonville restaurant to
that like and that happened over what I
think it was like six seven eight years
like it wasn't that long of a period of
time no it was two years I started at 17
I started opening franchises at 19
around the world how does that happen
well you know it was interesting I was
the first person in my family to get
into college ever so my plan was not to
like run restaurants my plan was to go
to school get a degree an engineering
degree I was a chemical engineering or
computer sciences and
Terkel engineering major with a desire
to go on to chemical engineering and
then I wanted to go to law school after
that so I had this very weird big super
fancy career path of engine you know
electrical engineering and chemical
engineering and then law and what
happened was I was working in a growing
company it just so happened that at that
time Hooters was growing around the
United States went around the world and
people who haven't worked in retail
might not know but it's super common
that when you open new units of a
business you take employees from the
existing units and take them to go teach
people how to do that job like that's
super normal what what's unusual is that
it was hooters that the first time I
ever went to go open a restaurant wasn't
sitting Australia because the company
was growing there I didn't even have a
passport I've never been on a plane when
they asked me to go open that franchise
but I said yes then I bought my first
ever plane ticket to Miami stood in line
got my passport and came back and
traveled and was a part of the team it
was a whole team of people from around
the country that traveled to Sydney to
go open that franchise and I really
thought you know it would never happen
again who would ask a girl like me like
child of a single parent alcoholic and
to go do this and the answer was hooters
because 60 days later I helped launch
the first ever of the franchise in
Central America a few months later same
in South America eventually Canada Asia
and before I knew it within 12 months I
was opening franchises all around the
world and I was failing college because
I was never there and I was really good
and in school when I was there but once
I started opening franchises I would be
gone for 30 40 days at a time in these
countries to launch the franchise to
help set up the supply chain to train
the employees to help train the managers
to get it going to do press and media
and help the franchise get started and
I'd come back I'd make up my classes but
eventually that just wasn't sustainable
and by the time I was 20 so in that
first year I started leading the opening
so I was no longer a member of the team
I was now a 20 year old launching
franchise
is bringing teams together and meeting
them and and then I dropped out of
college so I'm a college dropout because
I was never there and Hooters offered me
a corporate gig at the age of 20 to go
to Atlanta to oversee all employee
training and then it just fast forwarded
from there as the company grew I grew by
the time I was 26 I was vice president
of the company and then we were doing
about 750 800 million in revenue all
right when you show up at 19 20 years
old with two years or less of experience
actually working at the restaurant that
you're now helping open in foreign
countries what's the interaction with
the people who are gonna work there like
our people are just like what do you
know you're 19 20 years old or are they
like oh the woman from America has come
here to teach us how to do this like how
does that happen in terms of just you
being young and having to interact with
them assuming people who either are the
same age of you as you at the time or
older especially at that stage since I
was so young it's a mixed bag you know
the you think about the stakeholders are
very different groups so one is the
actual franchise owner which is
typically a very wealthy businessperson
from that country looking to diversify
their portfolio by opening restaurants
as a franchise and so typically those
people I had a working relationship with
in advance but just over the phone there
wasn't soon you know back then so I had
some relationship but they typically
didn't know how old I was
I've always sounded a bit older I've
always looked a bit older and while I
had never been asked to lie about my age
nor would I I was very well aware that
the impression was that I was older than
I actually was in fact when I was
opening restaurants that first year I
couldn't even legally Rent A Car I had
to lie I say I was 21 and or have
somebody else sign for it and just so I
could get that piece done and but then
the other trainers that I would bring
the team that I was leading it was a
mixed bag you know some would say hey
who are you you're younger than me you
haven't worked in this company as long
as me others would make a connection
with me very quickly which is why I had
to learn on the fly how to build trust
over and over again
people who I'd never met who I would
likely never see again it was a
different team in every country with
individuals who really had never seen
the brand or the concept before and I'd
say that's one of the benefits of that
early demand of having to travel to a
different country to do the same thing
with a different team over and over is
it it forced me to build the muscle of
openness vulnerability humility courage
you know a lot of things that seem
counterintuitive but became my secret
sauce of being able to go anywhere no
matter how young I was build a team
achieve an outcome and generally build
trust across the stakeholder group and
it feels like you're basically saying
like hey I had a lot of practice right I
got to do this over and over and over
again and the practice kind of makes
perfect one of the other things I'm
really interested in is many of the most
successful people that I talk to on the
podcast they've done a lot of traveling
and so maybe kind of like how did that
help you especially at that age being
able to go into all these different
cultures and meet so many different
people like is there things that you
either learned or you kind of look back
now on it you say wow that was a really
valuable experience because of X yeah
for sure one I mean literally Australia
was my first trip I mean other than
flying to Miami to get my passport and
so and yes it's an english-speaking
culture but but different right context
as different words are different and so
from that first opening I I really
learned the value of humility at the
same time I learned that if you're only
humble and curious you're just a student
and no one will follow you but if you're
only courageous and confident you're
you're a bull in a china shop possibly
even perceived as an [ __ ] and you can
get things done short-term but you'll
never have a team that lasts and things
won't get done when you're not in the
room and so I learned this tension of I
was confident but confidence didn't show
up as I know what I'm doing
always it showed up as I know I can
figure it out because I know I'm humble
and curious enough to ask questions and
get people to help me so the confidence
oddly was fueled by this humility and
curiosity and I would go in every
country there was something we had done
wrong every country and and yeah I was I
was good at international operations
over time because of practice but the
first few openings they weren't a hot
mess I mean there were things culturally
we hadn't done our research there were
certain aspects of the menu or the brand
or even the basics of the training
schedule that just didn't reflect the
nuances of a social culture a brand and
restaurant culture and employment
structure I mean there's so much you
don't understand if you aren't from a
place and it took two or three openings
in two or three different countries for
me to realize that Wow
the only common denominator between
these openings is me so if it's
consistently going wrong it's pretty
likely my fault and that's a brutal
leadership mirror you know to eventually
be like [ __ ] it's not them it's me and
what do I do about that and how do I
figure it out so I think because I was
alone there weren't a lot of other
resources from the company I was forced
to deal with my own mess and I was
forced to see where I was a common
thread in a problem and then my fourth
opening was in Argentina launching
Hooters in Buenos Aires first one ever
in South America I was 20 years old
might have just turned 21 and the
franchisee it was such a mess there was
so much we didn't understand about the
culture and the consumer there I could
go on and on about the specifics but it
was a mess I mean employees basically
didn't want to come to work even though
they're kind of contracted to come to
work and he sat me down and he said I'll
give you one piece of advice that I hope
stays with you throughout your life
which is anytime you're criticized
assume first that it's correct and he
said it's not your it's not the natural
activity for your brain you instantly go
into defense mode but assume first that
criticism is accurate and then what will
happen is
if you consider that and you reaffirm
that it's actually not instead of
debating the what you focus on the why
but if you in fact realize that even a
fraction of it might be accurate it will
keep your foot out of your mouth it will
help you bridging whatever that gap is
learning unlearning fixing and create
far more respect over time and progress
and so though those are some little
things that balance of curiosity and
humility on one side courage and
confidence on the other that literally
is the formula to going anywhere doing
anything in almost any culture but also
that piece of advice from that
franchisee and that allowed me to just
iterate on the fly every time I would
get an input I'm gonna assume it's
correct is it oh yeah it kind of is okay
let's change that instead of getting
caught up and like ego battle or we're
the franchise or you're the franchisee
or this is an American brand do it our
way it really helped me iterate and
innovate and be fluid in ways that
allowed without a lot of experience for
me to seem as a more mature and
experienced leader than I actually was
yeah and at some point you build the
experience right because eventually they
ask you to step into kind of the
vice-president role you kind of grow
into that and one of the things that I
forget who said this it might have been
maybe the CEO of wealth font wrote a
blog post I think basically was aiming
advice at college graduates right he was
saying hey look there's basically three
paths you have most of you are gonna sit
you're gonna evaluate two of them which
is good join a large tech company or go
try to start your own business and
because actually those might not be the
right decisions because the best thing
you should do is go find like a Series B
company that's kind of not guaranteed to
succeed but it's definitely growing and
get in there it's really easy if you're
a good performer to get more and more
flexibility and kind of grow with it and
then the best part is if they're
successful whether you did something or
not like it's on your resume and you'll
basically get the credit for being good
early at this thing that group so I've
always thought of that as like that's a
pretty prescient piece of advice for
college graduates you basically did that
without even really knowing it in the
sense of this thing went from I think
I've read that it was you know
hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue to upwards close to a billion
dollars when I left and you basically
literally go from a waitress to you're
in charge of all employee training and
development like talk a little bit about
just like what does that experience like
kind of you growing and getting more and
more responsibilities as the business
itself is growing and like over some of
the takeaways from that one it's what it
felt it at the time I think when I
reflect I remember far more of the
positives than I do the pain I think
that's how we operate as humans I know
that as someone who's given birth to two
children it's sort of like in my memory
now but in the moment that was not fun
you know I think one is when you're
moving up really quickly it is likely
that you continue to go from a position
to being elevated and now you're
managing your peers and then again
you're managing people who were your
peers the day before and there is
something about that accountability
where they know you right you were all
doing the same thing you were the ones
having coffee and lunch talking about
what's going on in the business and all
of a sudden you're the person you were
previously talking about and when that
happens over and over one it really
helps you sit up a lot straighter and
whatever job you're in today because you
you know it's pretty likely that you
might actually be managing your peers
and so it I think when you believe
you're going to be under the bright
light of scrutiny that you just do a
better job there's something really
powerful for those who care about how
they're perceived the other is there are
a lot of these forks in the road given
that same set of conditions where now
I'm managing my peers and some people
can only improve incrementally in those
situations because the way they believe
they are viewed by their previous peers
holds them back you know I can't be
someone materially different in 24 hours
after the promotion because I was just
this other person yesterday yet some
people will leave a company go get crazy
deep experiences come back and be a
completely different person
and I believe you can make just as much
change inside of a company but it takes
a lot more courage because you do have
to deal with people saying hey wait a
minute if that wasn't that important to
you yesterday and you have to be able to
say you're right I was wrong about that
now it is here's why I'm going to do a
better job to make sure people who were
in the position that I was in yesterday
understand that so that's one learning
of moving up quickly and being so young
is I was i watched others have
opportunities to move up but then they
got held back by trying to be a part of
the crew instead of owning their full
new responsibilities in that role and I
like to think of it as a seat at the
table and if you're not using your voice
and making an impact you're taking up a
seat you know get out if you're not
going to do the job and and I observed
that of others and I didn't want to be
that person the other thing was that
there were very literally many moments
where my judgment or my mere being there
was questioned either literally to my
face which I always appreciate more or
behind my back and then I would hear
about it separately far less because of
gender actually because in that company
there were a lot of women leaders every
person I worked for until I worked for
the CEO was a woman actually so I had
many examples and mentors of how to show
up as a woman I was never trying to
figure out how to like be an executive
in a man's world which was this really
beautiful gift but there were many
people who because of my age and how
quickly I moved up again said directly
or to other people I don't understand
why she's here she's too much of a
cheerleader you know there were
definitely those sort of the presence of
the patriarchy or the misogynistic
beliefs because I was 26 and my peers
were 60 and they had been in business
longer than I had been alive and I had
to realize that most of those people I
was not going to be able to change you
know they're so set in their ways I
could only change me so I learned to
navigate that environment I learned to
turn my personality up a little and turn
it down a little but to never be someone
I'm not but to respect the experience
culture
in ways of other countries and other
people those were hard lessons they were
emotional at times there were times that
I would go home and tears because it was
just hard right the normal politics that
are at work and then add different
gender college to drop out not as
sophisticated former Hooters girl half
their age there's a lot going on there
that even if they didn't put it out
there was in my head and it's a symptom
of being the only in a room the only
person of color the only woman the only
young the only college dropout
and so I I respect that a lot now as a
leader when there are people who are the
other or the only or the minority I
really think about the things that might
hold back them giving their full selves
because there were times that I held
myself back on that journey and I think
it's a great piece of advice in terms of
you learn that lesson the hard way right
of actually going through it but it
actually makes you a better leader now
because you can come a spot
hey that person is likely to be going
through some of the things that I
understand and have personal experience
with you've told me before that as you
were kind of going through this journey
and growing within the company it wasn't
just people internally that realized hey
she knows what she's doing there was
lots of people outside of the company or
maybe a few people who would come to you
and basically say hey do you want to go
run this or do you want to you know join
my company over here or do whatever but
you stay for a while or you say yeah and
years and kind of maybe talk a little
bit about like why did you turn down
some of those opportunities and then
like what caused you or incentivize you
to ultimately leave and go join Cinnabon
you know part of it was the company was
growing so fast and we were almost fully
vertically integrated so we owned our
own supply chain we owned her own
merchandising company it was like six
companies we had our own airline Hooters
air it was a thing look it up it's a
really bad idea but nonetheless it was
another company it was so rich with
business education and leadership
opportunities and again at such a young
age
and and in the early days and I stayed
there for just under 15 years and and in
the early days the first 10 years I was
like man who again who would ever give
somebody my age opportunities like this
I wouldn't get through their HR filter
for real literally they would never call
me back if it was just on a piece of
paper so there was a part of me that
felt I was getting such amazing
experience that everything else seemed
so boring when other brands that were
much bigger less controversial you know
less edgy wanted me to come be the chief
such-and-such right chief HR officer
chief operations officer there was these
really president of a small company
there were these really interesting
offers early on when I've been a vice
president for a few years and I thought
about them I thought I'd sure be nice to
just change the story right to like not
be with the same company but then when I
looked under the hood it's like oh you
mean I'm gonna be pigeonholed and a
functionality in a company that's
already so set in its ways no thanks
like it my currency is learning I turned
down a lot of money
unfortunately my currency is learning
and I knew it early on and anything that
would try to get me to trade off
learning for cash was not an acceptable
trade-off then and it's not an
acceptable trade-off for me now that's
part of why I stayed I mean it Ken were
running an airline we're buying hotels
were navigating selling our
manufacturing division and I was in the
middle of all of that if not leading a
good bit of it and that was like glue
man it was like gravitational pull the
growth the diversity of business and and
it's a little bit hard to leave when
you've amassed so much relationship
capital right I could do anything in
that company up to a certain point I
enjoy a great degree of flexibility and
a great degree of impact and the company
was my family I mean I was there for
again 14 years so that was what kept me
my last
year and a half there I went back to get
my masters so I have a master's without
a bachelor's I went to school nights and
weekends
an Executive MBA program at Georgia
State and I did it because I wanted to
round out my financial acumen I mean I
knew I was a sure bet from a business
perspective I knew I could brand and
rebrand a company in any country around
the world I knew I could start and train
operations I knew I could build teams
and build franchises I had confidence in
myself but I also knew I had limitations
on the language I would speak with
external stakeholders lawyers any type
of private equity firms I might be
looking at the business and right as I
was in the middle of getting my MBA we
had to sell the company the owner and
CEO had to guide his son had taken over
and to settle the estate we had to put
the company up for sale and so I was
literally going to class at night
learning about transactions of
enterprise valuation then going to meet
with lawyers and private equity firms
the next week and saying everything that
I knew operationally but able to
communicate in a language that garnered
respect and allowed allowed us to really
optimize the story of the company
through that process that sale process
and also through a lot of my volunteer
work in the industry I was the chair of
the board of the Georgia Restaurant
Association when I was like 25 26 years
old so I did a lot of political advocacy
for the industry those parallel lives
the you know the management
presentations for the company and the
industry Association work gave me a lot
of visibility and people in the industry
including private equity firms started
to see me as a leader with a crazy
amount of potential not just the
executive at Hooters if I had just been
that executive at Hooters on paper I
wouldn't have been offered the
opportunity to be the president of
Cinnabon which was what eventually got
me to leave I didn't think I'd get the
job they asked me to interview I had
been talking to the private equity firm
for quite some time about working with
them Roark Capital out of Atlanta and
they offered me a job to run one of the
portfolio companies and turn it around
in the middle of the recession
that was that was interesting enough to
learn and to grow and I was excited for
you have to change the change the page
get another chapter going so you lost
over an important thing here which is
you went and got an MBA without a
bachelor's degree how do you do that
it's still not common today which is
surprising considering the state of
higher education and business schools I
here's how it went down and this is why
having access to people with experience
in business and in life matters this
woman who has always taken an interest
in me who over time became a mentor I
don't believe in really pushing and
mentoring and mentors on people it feels
daunting it feels inaccessible to those
who are like me who aren't like Wharton
grads high potential right it's it feels
it just feels tough and but I do believe
in mentoring moments I do believe in
mini mentoring I believe in asking
anyone the assistant the the driver of
the truck the server or an executive I'm
dealing with this have you dealt with it
can you give me your perspective I
believe in amassing that and I did that
with various people and sometimes you
you really love what you get when you
have those exchanges and this woman and
I have a lot of these exchanges and she
took an interest in me and she called me
a couple years into being an executive
at Hooters and she said you know if you
want to get a job in this industry
you'll have no problem because you have
such a strong reputation but if you want
to do anything outside of franchising
and restaurants you will not get past
their HR gait you have got to get a
degree and I'm like oh but I dropped out
right before the I got my second year
degree my two-year degree and I've tried
to go back online and I'm just so busy
and it was just her telling me that it
was possible she said you know I know
the CEO who's running an enormous
corporation who this had the same
situation and he went back and got his
MBA through an Executive MBA program and
it's not common you have to take your
GMAT or your GRE very quickly and make a
hire typically a higher than is
typically required score to get in
because they've got a you know mitigate
their risk but it's possible and
all I needed to hear was that it was
possible I went I applied to every
business program with campuses and
Atlanta Georgia State Georgia Tech UGA
Emory got into most of them and then
chose Georgia State so that that's how
it went down it's amazing and and it's
also a thing I think of you took it as
like once I know something is possible
then I can go do it but what's our
exposure right if you're never exposed
to somebody who did it right it's like
no hey it can happen but then when so
many points that says that guy did it
like well that guy did it that I could
do it right changes the way people think
about opportunities not just it could
happen but it has happened that there's
the person who did it makes it more
believable yeah and I I think and I love
that you're double-clicking on that
because it also speaks to not keeping
your access and what you've been exposed
to in a little treasure box right it's
not people who do that have a scarcity
mindset have a zero-sum mindset if I
tell you then it's less you know it's
less special or I was the one right I
was the one person and I talk about this
everywhere to everyone because I want
everyone to know that it's possible and
I don't believe it devalues the
education or the merits of the
experience because look what I've done
since then right out it was a it was a
good bet on their part and it was a good
risk on my part and so I think there are
many things like that little things we
are all exposed to that in any audience
whether it's on Twitter in a clubhouse
room at a house with friends just
sharing those nuggets that secret sauce
I mean that helps democratize access to
opportunity completely agree you get in
and you're the president of Cinnabon you
said you didn't think you're gonna get
the job but you get it what do you do
like the first 30 days ranked as your
what you're like early 30s at this point
31 okay so you're 31 years old I'm
assuming that you step in and people are
still like what is that young lady here
doing like she thinks she's in charge
and then you compound it with as you
said earlier like the executive from
hooter
what does she know about Cinnabon or
restaurants you can just imagine all of
the kind of water-cooler talk like what
do you did you know I think what I did
is so much a framework or a primer for
doing a lot of things today not just
being new in a role or taking over a
company but I just went and worked in
the restaurants and spent time with the
franchisees you know all those questions
are about the surface of me the story of
me the minute we're having a discussion
and talking about the business and I'm
learning to roll cinnamon rolls it's not
about that anymore right all you have to
do is just go like an inch below and
connect with people and it just blows
that up and and now if you sit in your
ivory tower you sit in your office
behind your laptop yeah I mean that's a
big wall you have to break through your
your story your resume your reputation
whatever people want to decide they
think about you based on your age or
gender or experience
I just left know it I gave that zero
oxygen like just go straight in and do
nothing but work in the business and I
didn't do that because I I knew I was so
strategic intellectually to think oh I'm
gonna dispel all the myths about me I
did it because I actually wanted to
understand the business at a ground
level I did it because I it wasn't that
long ago that I was working in
restaurants in an hourly way and I
really respect that the answers are
actually all right there but what I've
learned is people who are closest to the
action which is the transaction and
business so call center drivers service
techs servers whatever the people who
are closest to the action know what the
right thing to do is long before the
leader does but they lack two critical
things they lack the language to
articulate the scaled problem or a
scalable solution and they lack the
authority to do something about it it's
the leaders job to come you like come in
and ask a lot of questions see the
patterns emerge from that and go ah even
though they're saying it in different
ways this is the common thread of the
problem or the opportunity and
this is actually what they're saying is
the fix and now I can do something about
it that's why all I did for the first 30
60 days was work in the business and in
fact I came out of that experience with
a blueprint of what I believed had the
highest likelihood to turn the business
around in the middle of the recession
and it worked so when you go in you can
roll cinnamon rolls you can kind of do
everything well dry you could try to do
all that but you're still the president
of the company right how do you kind of
build the trust with somebody who is the
cashier who is the truck driver who kind
of they're not used to everyday like you
say the language is one piece but the
fact like the president of the entire
companies here you can just imagine like
yeah the stores probably a little bit
cleaner the day you show up right and
everyone I'm on their best behavior how
do you build the trust with them in a
short period of time to actually be able
to get the truth right so when you ask
that question it's not like oh the
franchisees said that you know our
biggest problem is we need X actually
the biggest problem is that you know we
don't have enough throughput on the
tables or something like that and so
like how do you build that trust to get
that information yeah I love that you
use the word truth I am obsessed and I
think there's such a thing as a true
truth and then a created truth as you're
saying like the stores cleaner and that
piece of equipment that's actually
broken somehow isn't there and there's
like tape all around in the back I'm
obsessed with the truth I'm obsessed
with the truth and I believe I never
know it fully so the first way I built
the trust is actually not with those
crew members it's with the layers of
management that exists between me and
them because if I don't do my best to
create a warm entry where I at least
have a conversation of what my
intentions are assuming they are not
used to this type of leadership if I
don't do that what will happen is before
I arrive they'll go tell everyone
everything you said be on your best
behavior don't mention this and in it in
one way you can look at that and say
well that's a really low integrity
management
it's also human right it's also natural
and again formed by whoever managed
previously and I respect that so the my
first stakeholders are the group of
people between me and them for me to say
I am NOT coming in here to play gotcha
if I hear something
that would embarrass you or make you mad
just know I'm not going to flip out I am
NOT going to use what I hear or see as a
weapon unless it is illegal or immoral
right that if something Bad's happening
everybody's going down I'm gonna be like
that Elmo and fire meme but it but in
general everything else I grew up in
this business I get it
there are angry employees there are bad
employees their employees some good
ideas if I get it all but I have to
honor that I need to prime that those
layers of leadership so that I have
optimal access without it and still
they're going to do what you said so
that's step one that a lot of leaders
overlook because they're not thinking
about all the subconscious self talk the
the trauma the personal professional
trauma that all humans bring to the
table and the fear that that can put in
their minds if leader leader leader
comes in all of a sudden so that's step
one step two is just coming in and
working beside them and and literally if
I go in a business
let's talk restaurants I advise a lot of
consumer businesses and tech businesses
that let's just talk restaurants as an
example I put my hair up I wash my hands
I put gloves on right I'm showing
respect I'm leading by example I'm
saying I'm assuming I'm going to get
dirty back here even that step some
people don't do they keep their office
you know persona when they enter a
kitchen and I won't ever criticize that
because everyone's got their way but for
me I to answer your question of how like
how to get to the truth those are those
are my approaches and it really does
make people comfortable I asked about
them how long they've been here and then
I have very specific questions that I
ask and I ask the same questions to
everyone because I'm also looking for
patterns and if you ask different
questions you is too much noise in that
data even though it
it's qualitative there's still a lot of
noise and I asked when do we say no so
when do you have to say no when does
someone tell you no you know that that
shows me a window of opportunity if
people are asking for something
employees or managers or customers
consistently across locations over time
that is clearly saying there is an
employee or a market opportunity then I
ask what do we throw away or what do we
not use that we have and that's about
wasted resources so I'm I'm looking to
find wasted resources so I can fund the
thing that people are telling me is the
opportunity and then I ask if you were
me what's one thing you would do
differently to improve the business and
and not if you were me what's your
advice that's way too big what's one
thing you would do differently to
improve the business and there are
always patterns and honestly the answer
to that question often affirms or
dispels the prioritization of the other
things I've heard from that from the
first two so that's how I do it and it
helps me get to the truth it helps build
a good culture around that it helps
model the behavior so other leaders
start to do that and don't distance
themselves from the engagement of the
front lines it's really interesting to
hear you talk about specifically doing
things like you go and you wash your
hands put your hair up they call that
kind of stuff I was in the motor for a
while and one of the things that they
like thank you for your service it was
best years of my life but one of the
things that they work over and over and
over again and a lot of the leadership
schools is never ask somebody who is you
know one of your soldiers to do
something that you're unwilling to do
yourself right and so you can imagine
that military setting there's all kinds
of crazy stuff you could ask people to
do in the business setting same thing
right if you're not willing to go
actually make the food or wash her hands
would do whatever then you're actually
in some way telling them is that
important right so there's a
reinforcement there's a flip side to
that which is also know when you're in
the way and some people are like I'm
here you know let me it's getting busy
let me you know what happens when it
gets busy I take out the trash and I
wash the dishes and I get out of the way
of the people who
we're the experts because that's not the
time right that's not the time like is
not the time to chat it's not the time
to try to be helpful in things in which
I am not practiced and so that also
shows respect it's a it's a removal of
ego I don't need to be I need to serve
you because what I ultimately get is
your ability to do your job as best as
possible drives the business and if I'm
anyway I'm even distracting you or
making you think you have to perform for
me and not do what it is that you need
to do it's it's putting myself first
instead of other people so that's the
flip side I see some leaders who get it
half right you need to go in and they're
visible and they shake hands and kiss
babies and then they stand right in
front of a customer who's trying to
order and I'm like you know they don't
they're not really sensitive and again I
don't criticize because maybe they
didn't come from ups so they're just not
as attuned to it but if you're a great
leader of people running extensions of
your business you need to know that
stuff you need to understand how to get
out of the way
literally and metaphorically and any
type of business dtc tact retail
brick-and-mortar construction services
doesn't matter that's a really important
spidey sense to develop yeah that's
awesome
what was the PlayBook that you
implemented to turn Cinnabon around
three things
so first through those conversations I
diagnosed that there was a deficit of
belief just the franchisees were tired
there in malls this was like pre
e-commerce boom so there was another
wave of this coming but there was
depressed discretionary in common when
there's a recession a deep one like that
one in 2010 there are two things people
stopped doing shopping and traveling so
just traffic right and top-line sales
were in the toilet for a couple years
and they were tired the brand was
beloved but the business model was
jacked like you know these small
businesses average unit volumes half a
million a year they you know that if
you're close to break-even you're in a
scary place once you get past it they
they can print money but if you're in
that danger zone and these are small
business owners in large part it's
really scary so there was a lot of
emotion
fatigue around being involved in the
business and there was one large
franchisee that was like basically
running a Ponzi scheme and was insolvent
and I was dealing with a potential
bankruptcy of one guy that owned like
you know over a third of the system so
that was interesting
and so the playbook was first diagnosing
that that deficit of belief had to be
healed and I had to without being able
to fix the economy I had to help feed a
different dynamic where people would
believe believe in the franchise or
believe in the potential of the business
model and be re-energized around the
potential for the brand and the product
so that was first and that meant me
leading and literally telling people how
much I believed in the media and to
franchisees and met me making some
decisions in the company that
subconsciously indicated I believed
there was a positive future like doing
things for them that you wouldn't do if
you believed that the business was
headed to the bottom so that was first
was diagnosed and addressed the deficit
of belief the second was to focus on the
fundamental business model and so from
because it was so impacted by the
recession the actual unit level
economics were crumbling because there
were various things that worked pre the
recession that weren't during and
probably weren't going to serve the
business on the other side so that meant
answering and out of the questions that
I asked what do we throw away and when
do we say no telling me what the
opportunities were using those insights
to launch smaller products streamlined
SKUs really basic blocking and tackling
things but that helped improve
profitability and drive transactions and
then the third so that was that those
were the two foundational pieces and
then the third was launched a
multi-channel business that we've gotten
so famous for you know well over a
billion dollars in multi-channel sales
outside of the franchise business across
these licensed channels so Pillsbury and
Keurig and Green Mountain they're
Cinnabon Coffee Center Vaughn coffee
creamer Cinnabon Syria I mean you name
it right the brand
and its flavours and its ingredients
really represented a tremendous market
opportunity if we could think outside of
our franchise business model and that is
as big of a business today as the
franchise business and then we used that
to build a multi-channel ecosystem to
elevate the brand so there that third
piece is really important because I
think that people who've never looked at
a franchise business either as the
operator to purchase you know from
investor or franchisee C or even worked
at one they think of everything inside
those four walls and frankly that's how
most people kind of historically did
think about it right was just like how
do we drive more people into this store
so that we can then sell them whatever
the the food widget is that we have I
think you were one of the first and as
you said kind of pioneered this idea of
like wait a second there's a sign
outside it has a name on it that
everyone recognizes and how do we take
that land with all the ingredients and
things we do and we're known for all I
can stuff and then get it out of these
four walls right and that to me is not
only one kind of creative thinking or
thinking outside of the box that I'm
sure some people could come up with but
how did you actually execute that right
like what do you do from okay we have
Cinna bonds but how do I take this brand
and actually drive a billion dollars in
sales right I like what's the execution
steps today the first piece is really
understanding and cleaning up the brand
architecture a lot of people can
innovate products from their core and go
stick it in a bunch of channels doesn't
mean it's going to be successful so
deeply understanding the essence of the
brand which means answering the
questions where does this brand have the
permission to travel and in what product
forms does it make sense in various
channels like you've got to get really
honest about that and we got lucky I
didn't start the licensing business we
had the Pillsbury deal when I joined but
then we built everything on top of that
because it was so obvious that there was
permission
for the brand to live in people's homes
if we got the format right and then we
put the brand in other restaurants we
put mini bonds at Burger King and little
Cinnabon delights at Taco Bell and now
there's a product at Pizza that you can
order little tiny like mini mini 80
calorie cinnamon rolls and and many more
but it started with understanding like
we're how can we get this wrong because
the reality was and is we have this
legacy business so think of any business
you have a legacy business that is still
where a majority of the cash comes from
even if it's waning in relevance it's
still the trunk of the tree and if you
go making this huge heavy branch not
thoughtfully it can pull the tree over
and so and there's no shortage of brands
that you could point to that you're like
why would they do that and why would
they go there and a lot of restaurant
brands over the years have had something
in the freezer section or what you know
or whatever but it's a little side
hustle it's not an intentional brand
building and highly profitable business
division and that's what we that's what
we build it it wasn't a joke and it
wasn't a way to just market our brand
like these are legitimate lines of
business that are again now equally as
large in revenue to the company and
actually 75% of the consumer sales
across the whole world out of the
hundred percent of all things sold
Cinnabon about 70 to 75 percent depends
on the year are sold outside of the
franchise business even though the
franchise business is still what we're
famous for right so the first step is
diagnose the brand so you keep yourself
out of the gutter that helps give the
guardrails for where you should go in
what formats with what partners in what
sequence and and even silly things like
what do you call things is Cinnabon a
brand is it a thing is it a place you
really have to understand that should it
only be hot products since we're known
for being hot we did just launch
Cinnabon ice cream it's delicious with
Briers so the answer was always should
be hot unless it's a spiced cereal or an
ice cream and because it had other
attributes so we
down the attributes of the brand that
were rooted in the attributes of the
product and then we used that as a
framework to lay over any opportunity to
ask does this opportunity check enough
of these brand boxes and will it
translate in this channel because in
malls that's a very low frequency
transaction one or two times a year
that's it grocery is every week the same
product that wins and malls is not going
to win in grocery right something that
indulgent that you would only buy twice
a year you're you're only gonna buy it
twice a year in grocery and that's
missing the market so understanding the
pieces that can translate that is I
wouldn't even say that's step one that's
like the foundation of the pyramid you
get that wrong in any place you take a
brand or product format is likely to
fail
the second is some type of framework for
what partners you're gonna work with we
you know blue chip partners what do they
have that we don't what do we have that
they don't and how do we think about
that and choosing partners and contract
terms that has to do with exclusivity
blackout windows who owns the IP right
who who pays for what all that is the
second tier you figure out where your
brain can go and then who do you want to
go there with and then the I would say
the top of that pyramid which is maybe
small in size but it is the point of the
spear is understanding with the legacy
business how to ensure that this is a
collaborative ecosystem not a new
innovation channel that steals from the
core right it's not like I don't know if
you remember that book since I have a
toddler The Giving Tree where you just
keep giving up a piece of piece and all
you're left with is a stump it's got to
be a creative ubiquity where I have to
go to franchisees and say even though
this is a branded thing being sold
somewhere other than you it's not going
to take away from you and it's actually
going to build the brand create fans
draw interest and create a revenue
stream that will allow me to keep
reinvesting in the legacy business so
the pulling those things together with
the legacy business as a ecosystem and
of silo and silo and silo is is
literally the roadmap it is the secret
sauce and there's a lot within there
obviously and we made our share of
mistakes because we moved fast with a
lot of partners at once in new products
so I can share all the screw-ups too but
that's a bit of the framework so there's
one mistake that you made that you've
told the story before we don't have to
say who it was with but there was a
product that you created and you
basically did what you just said right
you went to the franchisees and you
basically said hey look we're gonna do
this it's not to hurt your sales there's
very specific kind of next in sandbox
that it's gonna happen in and we're
gonna go put it in this other store like
trust me don't worry and I say all that
because I think the first step is like
you pretty much did all the steps that
like a good leader would do when
potentially doing something that the
franchisees in the core of the business
they could get upset right and like oh
you're gonna take away sales from my
store by driving people to go buy that
the other stores that you're gonna go do
this with maybe tell us as much as you
can like what happened and like what the
mistake was and then really what I want
to focus on is like how you were able to
as a new leader of an organization kind
of use it as an opportunity to actually
build trust and in a better relationship
with franchisees even though there was a
mistake made yeah most people ask the
question when they hear the story how
did the board not fire you you do avoid
that so I was 90 days into the job and
had maybe maybe 120 max I don't remember
exactly and all the things that we've
discussed that I did to build trust to
turn around the business were well
underway franchisees were loving me I
was loving them I built trust we were
still just coming out of the recession
and their sales were growing their
profitability was improving and they
were like this lady knows what she's
doing and then I did what you said I
went to them and said we're launching
these products and other channels here's
what it is it's different than what you
sell but similar and it's going to be in
this large club grocery chain and they
said we don't like it because it's kind
of
like what we sell but we hear you and we
trust you okay let us know how it goes
and then a few days later I get an email
from one of the franchisees the son of
the founder and I always joke literally
it's like an email with three letters
and font size 90 and it's
whiskey-tango-foxtrot
question mark question mark question
mark and he like leaned on the
exclamation point four lines of text it
was a big WTF email and he's a super
kind and mild-mannered man typically so
I get on the phone with him I do what a
lot of leaders don't do I didn't try to
cover my tracks I didn't try to I just
called it right time is bad time is bad
when there are problems you go compress
time go straight to the source the
person speaking out and I said what's up
Greg and he sent me another email with a
picture of a product in this grocery
training that was very different than
what I told them it would be it was the
almost identical in form to the products
that they sell in the franchise's six
large ones in a rectangular not ten tiny
ones in a round pan with drizzled
frosting sold for basically half the
price and he's like you can talk to our
lawyer like they had already started
emailing the pictures around everywhere
and it was just this feeling like how
did that happen this is under my watch
but there were other teams working on it
when I joined so I'm not really sure so
I said I need you to give me 24 hours
so I can figure this out and I'll call
you back so I did and and I mean
literally it's been an hour diagnosing
this there's so many mistakes and
leadership lessons but essentially I had
a really overzealous sales guy for this
new innovation channel with a new retail
partner and the way we were delivering
the product was different it wasn't
sending someone a fully-formed
manufactured food product which takes
well over a year to plan commercialize
and sell in we were sending them raw
ingredients and recipes so all you needs
a different recipe to make a different
thing and this sales guy sent them the
recipe for the big thing because they
said we want the real one and there
wasn't a gate or a process that was in
place for me as the
resident to know and catch that and some
people hear the story and go oh my god
what a low integrity sales guy I bet he
was fired and he wasn't well not not
that time you know not then but it truly
it wasn't it was the fact that I did not
have systems in place to catch what this
new channel allowed to be a much faster
process of change in innovation all our
stages and gates for innovation were
built on old CPG models of 18 months 24
months commercialization cycles this was
like 60 days and then when I thought
about it I had walked around the
building and saw different packaging
there were signs there were little signs
that should have prompted me to poke but
then I had that typical young leader
self talk in my head you know Who am I
to question them they've been here
longer than me they would never do
anything to hurt the business and I
failed in my role as a leader I had the
humility to ask the question Who am I
you know to question them but in that
moment I failed to have the courage to
answer it and the answer is you are the
effing president and if you don't ask
questions no one will and so I
acknowledged that I called Greg back and
said look we have the right to do this
we had the right contractual e and we
were selling 70,000 units a week so it
was like crushing it and we were making
we were on track to make millions and
millions from I mean it was huge and I
was gonna take a big chunk of that money
and plow it into the franchise business
so we had some really good visions for
how we would use this innovation revenue
but just because we had the right to do
something doesn't mean it was right and
we did not handle it properly and I did
not put the systems in place to catch
the variations in the commercialization
process so we killed the deal walked
away from millions it took many months
to unwind it and and ultimately I was
able to earn the respect of the
franchisees even though I was in tears
every night I had to go to the board and
the CEO and say we're walking away from
millions but the way I positioned it was
if you don't support me in doing this
which they did by the way without
hesitation if you don't support me in
doing this I
never be able to manage this group my
employees will feel shame the
franchisees will always believe I'm out
to make money off their backs and I'm
not being honest I don't fix this in a
big way and learn from it and improve
systems I'll never have their trust I'll
never be able to go get them to take a
leap of faith for future endeavors and
as time went on it became like the fish
story you know it's this famous fable in
the company of how I am a high integrity
leader and made a tough decision because
we didn't do things right and I made it
clear to them look this doesn't mean
when you whine you get what you want
this is me acknowledging we didn't do
this right but a funny thing happened we
made up I remember having a franchise
Advisory Council meeting and sitting
with those franchisees and getting teary
because they several of them hugged me
you know like thank you this is their
livelihoods that they're afraid of but
three months later I came to them and
said I have an opportunity to put actual
Cinnabon many bonds in 7,000 Burger
Kings which is far more potentially
threatening the nut grocery business and
they said because of how you handled
this other situation we support you and
that deal that Burger King deal
single-handedly between doubles and
triples they EBIT of the company for the
following years and had I not fixed the
problem that I had allowed to happen
there's no way we would have been able
to push that next innovation deal
forward and what I think it really just
goes to is like you did everything kind
of by the book in terms of you told them
hey this is what we're doing this is why
we're doing it trust me
which was kind of the important piece of
it and they did that and when I went
wrong like you said it almost seems like
you had no other choice other than
either lose everybody or go and
basically shoot yourself in the foot but
it was because you want me to do the
right thing over a long period of time
rather than just make money in the short
term and then who knows kind of how it
plays out is that kind of fair to look
at that trade-off yeah and I think but I
do think that these are business people
who have other business endeavors and
have been around banks and financial
sponsors who would have said sorry
you're right we didn't handle it
properly we'll do better next time we're
keeping it right and then everybody
would just have to lawyer up if they
wanted to honestly we had the legal
right so it would have gone in our favor
and then eventually they would have been
disgruntled but we would have moved
forward so a lesser leader different
leader I should say could have easily
made the alternative decision and still
found a way to move forward but never
with the speed and impact that we were
able to move forward as a result how do
you go from president of Cinnabon to now
president and CEO of focus brands a
little bit about what is focus brands so
focus brands is essentially the parent
company it started out as just a holding
company where focus would buy you know
focus bought Carvel that was the
beginning of focus brands and then
bought Cinnabon and then Mo's and
schlotz key you know and just kept
acquiring and at four brands all five
brands we have seven now we realized
that we really needed to leverage the
power of our scale in all the ways your
listeners and viewers would imagine
supply chain investing in consumer
insights technological investment we
weren't doing any of that when I was
president of Cinnabon I was the CEO of
Cinnabon right my team no real shared
resources other than some lawyers and
some parent company HR like that was it
it's a very different machine now we
have centers of excellence it's a mini
matrix structure where all the brand
presidents are there nine presidents
that report in to me that run each of
the brands and then the international
business and the licensing business they
have their teens but they also plug into
a marketing Center of Excellence in
digital Center of Excellence strategy
consumer insights that allow us to pool
the resources and get each of these
brands to be able to punch above their
weight far more than if they were
freestanding businesses with just
greater access to talent right we can
afford more talent people are more
interested in working in this bigger
company and those centralized
functions we can make smarter decisions
that allow what they do in their
businesses to be more successful so
journey has been the company has grown
and restructured as it's grown and much
like when I was at Hooters every time we
restructured I took a different and
larger role so I went from president of
Cinnabon turning that around for three
and a half four years then grew the
global channels division I was president
of that multi-channel business to do the
things we've been talking about like
extend ecommerce manufacturing and
licensing to more of the brands than
just Cinnabon and Carvel and then put
all those things together and manage all
the businesses as president and CEO oh
now and it's been cool you know all the
interaction with those various stages of
hyper growth mergers and acquisitions
evaluating companies turning some down
getting getting some over the line
integrating them diagnosing their brands
and their fans and where they sit in
this in the spectrum of brand love and
what's special about them and how to
grow that in a franchise environment and
now 58 countries around the world 7,000
units and just under between four and
five billion in sales and it's been
interesting because it's actually helped
me be a better advisor to founders and
startups because these are big brands
but they're actually quite small
business we're constantly going from 0
to 1 or maybe never zero but one to ten
with franchisees constantly having to
help someone start from the very very
beginning while buying these businesses
at various places in their maturation
and working to reinvigorate them or
accelerate their success if that's what
they have so it's it's been interesting
and the parent company basically owns
the brand's owns the assets we operate
some of our own corporately owned units
to have skin in the game in addition to
franchising and we grow by acquisition
and I want to get into a number of
challenges that I know you guys are
facing just from an industry perspective
but before I do that do you ever wake up
in the morning or right before you go to
sleep and just smile and say like holy
[ __ ] I run a four to five billion dollar
revenue business like does that ever hit
you rather than oh I've got you know
this franchise here this year like you
have a very kind of operational way of
talking about an execution and and
more of the micro piece would you ever
just look at the macro picture and be
like damn this is pretty cool you know I
think it's I do but I don't wake up and
think about it that way I think about
the bigness of the brands when the
responsibility feels heaviest I feel
about I think about the bigness of the
brands when the responsibility feels
heaviest so when there's a problem when
we've made a mistake when there's a an
you know a big issue either in our
business or in the world that's when I
have the holy [ __ ] this is big
day-to-day not at all right I'm just in
it and I've got amazing leaders that
work for me and with me and my job is to
help them be able to do everything that
they can while harnessing the resources
of the organization and working on the
parent company's executive team to make
the parent company better and better
both for the existing portfolio and to
grow so it just it does we're just in it
right you're just doing it when there's
something big a big problem or a
challenge that we face as an individual
business or as a collective that's when
it feels heavy but it's also when I love
it the most because that our private
equity founder Neil aronsson says you
know we want to be a good partner in
good times and a better partner in bad
times and I feel like that every day is
a leader I want to be a really good
leader in good times and I want to be
like unbelievably amazing during tough
times and so that's when it feels heavy
but in an in a both oh my gosh way and
in a really positive way like wow we
have an opportunity to do something
really great in a big way if we can
figure out how to turn the Titanic I
love that I'm gonna go through each one
of these challenges and they're all like
I said kind of industry based and more
macro but maybe just talk through how
you guys have thought about it or
reacted the first is Cinnabon for
example is not the first thing I think
of when I think of healthy eating this
you know very large not helping
yeah there's this very large dietary
type dietary type kind of trends that
are going and so how do you think about
whether it's Cinnabon or some of the
other brands in terms of whether it's
marketing it's actually the ingredients
use the products you create like like
how has that changed as the world has
become more popular around various diets
and kind of being healthier no people my
assessment which is pretty well informed
from being in the industry but even just
as a consumer is that people still want
to indulge that's not that has not
changed what has changed is what we
consider worth it and so if we're going
to invest our discretionary calories or
our discretionary dollars it better be
so worth it and and that speaks to
product quality right and is it so
delicious that when I want to be bad and
eating a Cinnabon is totally being back
if I want to be bad it's worth it right
a bag of chips a pretzel what a waste of
dry cookie not worth it for me anymore
used to be when I was younger not worth
it anymore I want to be like really bad
because sugar is gonna do what its gonna
do regardless of what form it's in so it
better be so worth it in that moment and
treat me emotionally like I'm gonna eat
my feelings and feed my soul it's bad
for my butt but it's good for my soul so
that's the underlying belief is that
people want to indulge there is a place
for indulgent for that product segment
but what is required to be worth it and
therefore get people to vote with their
wallet it's far more product quality
which has meant for that brand over time
preserving the ingredient integrity
still making it rolling it in store you
go to the mall you go to the airport you
see them like rolling it by hand baking
it fresh that matters because that's
part of what makes it so good
it's worth it to be bad on the other
hand
it still has caused us the shift for all
of us and wanting to be more responsible
indulge errs to lean into smaller
portions like to make indulgences more
accessible and to have less sweet things
on the menu but over the years we've
tested gluten-free and sugar-free and of
course some people appreciate it truly
but not enough to make up for the waste
it truly most people like if I want to
be bad I'm gonna go and I'm gonna be bad
and we have Ross we have flour in our
environment we can't even do truly
gluten-free safely and because kids and
families come to malls and airports
that's too risky of a proposition to
market so that's the that's the
underlying belief is you there's still a
huge market for it but man it's got to
be it's got to be worth it and then that
drives all the decisions around product
around marketing I also believe it was
incumbent upon us to be really honest
that the brand is an indulgence and it
was one of the first things I did when I
took over I went on national television
and said don't eat it every day it's not
a good idea there are people who do it
but it's not a good idea
treat yourself and when you want to
indulge this is definitely something
that I would I would suggest is is worth
the indulgence but being honest that
it's a moment and an escape it's not
breakfast lunch or dinner yeah and one
other branch right so Cinnabon is the
the kind of the extreme example I could
probably look at that and say okay
that's not healthy for me but take Mo's
or some of the other brands that you
guys have like how do you have that
health trend with my own Southwest Grill
is so interesting because you know for
those that don't know it's a it's a
burrito chain and it's always had these
like an amazing line of fresh
ingredients you can eat like genuinely
healthy at Mo's but you can also eat
super not healthy like you can drink a
bowl of queso and it's amazing so so
what's changed for Mo's hasn't been
necessarily the food itself has been the
the
importance of articulating you can be
good or bad right you can eat for fun or
you can eat for wellness you can eat
keto or paleo here because we've always
had you know chicken and peppers and all
of these things that are super clean but
again you can also cover stuff and
cheese and queso and guacamole right
without trying to say we are the
healthiest place on the planet but
rather now with digital marketing being
able to segment and talk to people about
the different ways you can engage with
the brand because there's actually been
a possibility to be healthier or less
healthy for quite a long time like that
brand actually has the potential to be
more healthy than for a consumer than
most brands that we have but it has to
do with how you put that food together
yeah it's super fascinating the next two
challenges I think kind of go together
so I'll ask both at the same time which
is most of your locations are malls
airports in the novice you have
standalone as well but the malls and
airports are coming under pressure right
airports mainly from the cove in
nineteen and less travel and then the
malls just because of the secular trend
of like everyone thinks malls are going
away yeah how have you dealt with that
or kind of what decisions have you guys
made to kind of address that mitigated
or maybe capitalize on some opportunity
there I mean also a piece of that being
like an entire delivery you know
explosion during Cove at 19 I know you
guys are doing some of the malls as well
so he talked just about like physical
locations and delivery and kind of how
you navigate so much to unpack there so
malls Auntie Anne's is our only brand
that's a majority exposed to malls
Cinnabons even only one-third in malls
the other third are in Schlotzsky's
another third are in these like travel
centers on interstates so Auntie Anne's
is the brand that's the most exposed and
that's one of seven brands so it's
actually quite a small portion of our
total portfolio but it's a majority of
this one
normos brand that we have so the last
two year point the last several years
the trends of mall traffic ecommerce
siphoning off mall traffic
mall you know questions around malls and
their viability that's not new that's
been going on for almost a decade
what what is new is the acceleration of
those trends from kovat and from just
the increased adoption of e-commerce so
I'll touch on malls first and then go
over to delivery because the rest of our
business is Street side and so a couple
things are going on in balls one you
have different malls right you've got
ABCD malls they are what it sounds like
they are a super premium D hyperlocal
like center of the community in a
regional maybe even sleep your area C
and B malls have actually recovered
faster from covin because they are
centers of the community they're not
just a place to shop if a place is just
a place to shop it is equally the demand
shock is tremendous because you have
alternatives with e-commerce so leading
up to kovat one as you said was layering
in delivery even from our mall
businesses and that wasn't easy for a
couple years the malls didn't give
drivings
drivers their spaces it wasn't easy to
park and navigate these huge centers so
it was clunky at first but it got better
as it became very clear that this was an
important way to drive revenue for the
business so it got better over the last
18 months being able to deliver Auntie
Anne's Pretzels via ubereats or door -
or post mates which I guess is now
ubereats
or easy cater at catering businesses but
that's still only a portion of
incremental sales the lion's share was
still coming out of the business so a
few things one is learn how to increase
the capture rate of the people who are
coming in fewer people coming in figure
out a way to capture your larger fair
share of the business second of course
then was product development and other
channels meal kits pretzel kits other
things that helped drive revenue so it's
looking outside the mall for the
additional revenue opportunities
including delivery and DTC but then
optimizing for what's in the mall and
then having a longer
view of which malls are going to survive
which ones are going to do well as a
shopping and commerce center because
they're just that good like the owners
are going to keep plowing tens of
hundreds of millions over time into them
and which ones are going to have to be
meaningfully repurposed as an asset in
order to keep bringing traffic and some
of them are turning old Sears into
apartments some are turning it into
hospital and there's a lot of really
cool things you can do with that real
estate and if those developers figure it
out then there is still life even in
those malls for small food tenants like
our franchises and then there will be
some that are going to go away so we
have food trucks pop-ups hub-and-spoke
models there are many options like you
exhaust all these options before you
just say lights out you know in a
location and then remember the quickest
way to get out of a hole is to stop
digging so for the last three years
we've been opening more and more street
side businesses but co-branding and tri
branding so putting more brands more day
parts more occasions together reduces
the real estate investment risk and
gives us access to more non mall options
so that's the mall peace delivery we
were one of the first national chains to
sign up with post mates actually post
mates was the early mover in the food
delivery space before ubereats and
doordash really got traction and we were
one of the first when they were only in
17 cities and so delivery has been a
part growing part of our business for
well over five years but the last two
years it has become a material part of
the brick-and-mortar business then add
to the fact that we've been investing in
our own apps our own loyalty programs
you know all these things allow us to
have a direct relationship with our
customers as well as a direct way to
serve our customers that are something
other than come in order sit down
since we had that technology during
kovat we flicked on curbside in 48 hours
we were already testing it and had it
set up in some locations but because we
had made these investments we were able
to turn on different functionality not
just on the technology side but on the
operating model side that allowed us to
also launch meal kits and
Moe's market and other things that kept
us in business even when dining-room
business went away some of our brands
have not reopened dining rooms and are
doing priek Ovid sales just through
pickup windows delivery drive-thru
they're not all performing that that way
but several are so it's really
interesting to think about how this
accelerated innovation in some cases and
improvement and profitability in other
cases we're still figuring out how in
one operation to have all of these
revenue channels you know curbside and
pickup and pickup window and
drive-through if they have a drive-thru
and app orders and then the 10 15
percent of people that actually still
want to come in so that's a lot to
manage with a small crew so we're now
navigating the operational impacts as
all of that's converging and you have
the benefit obviously of having to seven
different brands how much of the
infrastructure around the technology for
let's say delivery and things like that
is shared and you're just kind of white
labeling it or relabeling it for each
brand versus you're actually building a
different technology stack for Auntie
Anne's versus Cinnabon versus the others
it's a great question one day it will
all be the same but because we grow by
acquisition you know we get what we buy
and sometimes we get something super old
that's at end-of-life and we need to
upgrade it anyway and when we do we
bring it on to our platform other times
it's it's not old it's not optimal but
it doesn't make sense to tear it apart
based on the financial equation and
other things you're working on so you
just tweak it and other things when we
bought Jamba they were at the very
beginning of a brand new technology
contract and it was just too unwieldy to
unwind and so we you know we had to work
our way around that but brand by brand
as the window represents itself we bring
them on to a common platform whether
that's web general digital commerce
loyalty apps and frameworks so it's it's
a journey but the utopia is common
platform so as we acquire brand you just
reskin put it on alter it for whatever
that business model is different
consumer frequency you know different
segments or pricing to your potentially
but otherwise keep bill
on the successes so we're about halfway
through that journey so you just talked
about as you acquire a new brand re
skimming it bringing it onto a platform
that sounds a lot like what ghost
kitchens are trying to do around being
very iterative any kind of thoughts
around either one using spaces you guys
already have to become ghost kitchens of
some sort or actually taking the brands
going into other ones or maybe even
creating new brands given all the
logistics and kind of food expertise
that you have like what are the thoughts
there yeah so we're pretty well down the
path of progressing toward external
ghost kitchens while recognizing that
during kovat some of our businesses were
ghost kitchens literally right nobody's
coming in there's no walk-up business it
is a kitchen and the only way you're
getting it to people is through some
form of delivery or off-premise
transactions so we think about it a few
ways one is we may have instances not as
the majority of our route to market but
in fill opportunities we're operating a
dark business non customer-facing
storefront is a really smart way to fill
in the geography because building a
full-blown brick-and-mortar just doesn't
make financial sense so that's I think
that's a very real possibility whether
it's inside of someone else's owned and
operated ghost kitchen or how we decide
to deploy our own real estate or
franchisees assets to operate a delivery
only or digital only storefront I think
there's a real market for that but it's
not going to be the only path you still
you still optimize sales meaningfully
when customers can walk up even if it's
just pre-order on the app and pick it up
myself or a curbside that's a that's a
big chunk of business and those
behaviors aren't going away I mean even
during kovat while we stayed open yes we
delivered more yes more people wanted it
delivered but delivery is expensive and
it takes time that sometimes isn't what
that app tells you it's going to be and
it frustrates people over time they feel
more control or it's
close to their house right so they just
are like I'll go make it up it's fine
and so that that behavior is not going
away there is a customer facing revenue
segment that if you are dark or ghost
only you're walking away from it get it
might be super smart especially in dense
urban areas but that's not the reality
of most of this country you know the
rest of it most of the country isn't New
York isn't is it the valley is it the
Bay Area it's not downtown LA its
Nashville it's wide spread out Atlanta
and people still drive like they have
cars and so they're gonna go it's easy
for them to go pick up food and until
the cost of delivery comes down and
until the speed of delivery is faster
and more consistent and that is
happening in dense areas but in the rest
of the country it's not until that
happens the the value of customer-facing
is still so big that you're not gonna
see brands walk away from that way you
will see as them maybe building less
dining-room space and more kitchen so
then you can fulfill more digital demand
more off-premise demand out of that into
your point if so inclined create other
digital-only concepts out of that back
of house says something you guys would
do yeah how do you Craig's McDon it's
you know when you're in a franchise
system you got to be careful with
spitting out a bunch of random brands
with IP you've got to manage but many
concepts have done it will do it will
play around with it to just understand
the opportunity but fundamentally we are
in the brand business and so if we're
not growing the big bets we've made of
these brands we've paid hundreds of
millions of dollars for and we're
tinkering around with I don't know I
talked trina's tacos out of the back of
a mows then we're not building Mo's
right so there there is a place for that
experimentation there's also an
opportunity cost when you really want
people making the most of that asset
you've invested in yeah and it also
feels like you're thinking much bigger
about the IEP as well right because of
all the other channels and things like
that's that make sense
I want to finish up talking about one
last topic which is you are a mother a
wife you run a four or five billion
dollar revenue business and then you
also have a bunch of non-business
interest in terms of I'll just call pro
humanity work right and activism how the
hell do you do all this like what do you
do from a Productivity standpoint and
like how do you structure your day in
time in order to accomplish all this
yeah it's it ebbs and flows
you know it's first my husband and I
have a monthly check-in so every month
we ask each other a series of questions
I've got a whole post and highlights on
my Instagram about it's actually really
important to enabling successful
business leaders where we keep each
other in check so if something feels
like it's you know shifting the
gravitational pull from where it should
be which is family or my health our
relationship and then our family first
we call each other out we'll do it real
time but we really talk about it in
these monthly check-ins so that that
helps just making sure nothing gets off
the rails we'd like to say our
relationship is like vines you know we
do things that are independent but they
should never get too far apart and peel
off and sometimes they should come
together really closely and so we try to
put structure in like business structure
in place to make sure that that happens
the next is I try to ask myself is what
I'm doing the highest and best use of my
time and sometimes I end up speaking to
a small graduate class or hanging out in
a small room on a virtual app with
people and some people might be like hmm
is that the highest and best use of your
time and in that moment I believe it is
either because I believe that group has
a disproportionate likelihood to then
ripple impact or because I have a
disproportionate opportunity to learn
from them I try to balance learning and
mentoring and giving throughout the day
and that doesn't mean just learning from
higher level more successful people and
learning from everyone like super young
people and people in different
industries I need to keep dipping my
brain into this like intellectual
chocolate that is the Internet
because it helps me it really does and I
love it I love making connections
virtually so I try to find easily an
hour to an hour and a half a day where I
can dip my brain into the intellectual
chocolate that is you know virtual
communities are the internet I just and
that might be a podcast it might be a
social app might be a virtual
conversation a conversation then I try
to make sure that I've just prioritized
my business responsibilities like my day
gig responsibilities do the most
uncomfortable least pleasing things
first
I've also learned for me that
procrastination is a sign of stress it's
a sign that I've said yes to too many
things rarely is it that I'm just
actually a procrastinator it's that in
that moment I've said no to too much in
my brain is I said yes to too much I
need to say no to more and my brain is
like trying to protect which is
ironically making it worse because I'm
not doing anything so I've learned that
about myself I do a lot of reflection I
do a lot of asking like why do I think
that and why do I feel that why am i
spending time on this and then making a
change so I use this practice called the
hotshot rule and the way I do ultimately
what you're asking is on a regular basis
for me it's weekly it used to be
quarterly and it was so effective I
started doing it more often I practiced
the hotshot rule I'll write a book on it
sometime soon because it's so powerful
and all the things that stem from this
mindset but I ask myself to think of a
hotshot just whoever is a mr. or mrs.
Potato Head of badassery like you other
people I've met I think of you and I
think if you were in my job tomorrow or
my life depending on what role am i
thinking of my role as mother my role is
wife my role is president of a company
what it's one thing if you had my seat
what is one thing and the first thing
you would do immediately because you're
a badass and because you have fresh eyes
and I can I can always think of that
thing always as soon as I put my
self in somebody else's like day one
fresh I mentality I know I know what the
one thing is and then I asked myself why
can't that be me and then I take action
on it in 24 hours and I realized and so
what I'm doing is I'm just improving
right every week by going through this
exercise
it requires vulnerability and humility
but also courage and confidence because
I'm having to disrupt something that I
was already permitting to occur or
actually do it and this happened when I
was I'd been president of Cinnabon for
four years and I've been using this
practice for 10 years but it really
showed up as a benefit when I was
president of Cinnabon because we did
turn the business around it was a wild
success
it still is a wild success and I
remember about right before I took the
next gig some of my team members started
nagging me about this franchisee that I
needed to basically get out of the
system and I remember I kept thinking
but he's not that bad compared to how
horrible the roji franchisees were I was
blinded by my own progress the things my
team saw as the biggest issues that were
unacceptable to me we're like oh it's
not that bad and I was failing them and
failing the company because I didn't see
it the way they saw it and so I
practiced the hotshot rule I what sat in
front of my team I always talked to my
team about it I say look I was I don't
sometimes I say the hotshot rule other
times it's much more conversational I
say I was thinking about it I realized
if any of you were in my job you would
take care of this and I did not I'm
thinking about it not I'm a I did right
I took action and every time I tell
people something I took action on as a
result of the hotshot rule and Evatt
ibly someone always says what took you
so long
because the people who are closest to
the action know what the right thing to
do is long before the leader does and so
this process of asking answering and
acting like over and over and over helps
me not get blinded by my own progress
personally or professionally
it helps me prioritize the right things
to get this stuff done
and it helps me make sure things are in
harmony there's no balance but that
exercise plus having a way to check in
with someone who loves me who cares and
I'm able to do the same helps us make
sure times not getting sucked by the
bright shiny light of some new interest
that's an awesome answer I think that's
super super valuable
before I end up asked everyone the same
two questions the first is what is the
most important book that you've ever
read I think the most important book
I've ever read is probably give and take
by Adam grant why you know he that book
explains a lot of what I've encountered
in my life and codifies it and I came to
know it because he as the author
actually reached out to me because his
first pass at the book people called him
out and said there aren't enough women
in the book and he said you're right
fair critique following the advice of my
mentor right somebody criticizes us and
first the right fair critique point me
in the direction of some women who
should be in the book and a few people
recommended me and he reached out to me
on Twitter and that's how I got to know
him and that's how I got to know the
book and so I was in later iterations of
his speeches and conversations around
this but talking to him is what got me
to read the book and he talks about the
value of a givers takers and then this
group in the middle write these
transactional maintain errs like I'll
give if you you give and the headline is
there's a role in the world for all of
them but givers as humans as long as
givers put things in place boundaries
protect themselves understand the
healthy way to give there's unhealthy
giving healthy givers always win in the
long run
and I had called it destructive
achievers and productive achievers that
was my word for it but in such a simple
way he's an organizational psychologist
he's a professor at Wharton an amazing
human it was something about codifying
it in that way that was so simple that
explained such a spectrum of behavior
and didn't attack it or make it personal
it just said this is right and there's a
way to be aware of it and there's a way
to help people move to a more giving
place and there's also again a dark side
of giving if you don't understand how to
do it healthily
it was the most in a very simple way the
most profound book about humanity and
leaders and there are so many others
that I think you where I could talk
about that are like really interesting
and deeply intellectual and talk about
like the evolution of humanity over eras
but that book is it's accessible it's
simple yet profound and I hope that when
others read it they really think hard
about where they are in those groups and
whether or not they're where they want
to be it's awesome second one's a little
bit more fun which is aliens believer or
non-believer Oh believer why super
believer because it's gonna be her super
believer or believer like they're out
there dancing on some planet right now I
I believe for a few reasons one because
I'm one of those people that believes in
something or assumes the potential for
it when it has not been disproven right
like you can argue it hasn't been proven
it hasn't been disproven therefore there
is the potential for it and I just
I just can't believe we're alone like
this can't be the only time magic and
evolution and all of these things like
it just it can't be like statistically
it can't be
so and it it's fun to believe it's super
fun to believe it so yeah that's why a
prior guest Bruce Fenton came on and he
said every human asks the same two
questions at some point in their life
and the first is what happens when I die
and the second is are we here a lot and
I think they're like that pretty much
sums it up right it is you wanted to
believe positive things in both of those
scenarios for sure for sure I end with
letting the guests ask me a question so
what question do you have for me what do
you wish people knew from your
perspective if you just think about what
you're seeing in the world things that
run through your mind could be about you
could be just your perspective on the
world like what's across your mind where
you're like if I had a way to convince
people to know this or believe this what
do you wish people knew really easy and
the context here is I obviously have the
pleasure of talking to so many different
types of people both in kind of the day
job stuff this on Twitter all these
different apps etc but everyone thinks
just we have way more in common than we
have different right I mean I think that
like the world spend so much time
talking about focusing now on and
highlighting differences but at the end
of the day like there's way more
commonalities and there's differences
and it feels like that's the one thing
if people remembered that it would solve
a lot of problems but it would at least
drive us closer to solutions because
when you focuses on the differences it
creates all the tribalism and divisive
Mis and like all that but just we're all
human we're all gonna live hey Doc
remember
that if they don't act but you know that
because she as you said you're talking
to so many people right you just it's
constantly in your face that we're more
alike and it requires connection to be
reminded that we're more alike than we
are different and it's crazy too because
I can think back and like I'll have a
conversation with you and you'll
literally say something and I'll be like
I've heard that four times before and
when you're talking earlier about like
oh I go and I talk to the different
people that are actually the cashier or
the truck driver or whatever and I'm
looking for the patterns like you'll say
something and I'd be like I've heard
four other people say that and by the
way they don't look alike they don't
come from the same background stand out
the same jobs like no but they are
literally good at something and
therefore here's the pattern and you
just started to think about like oh it's
because we're all so similar rather than
so different and so you know that's like
the big takeaway from me it's just like
we're not really that different I think
it's it's one of the reasons that my
friend Kate Atwood who founded Cates
Club she's an expert in childhood grief
she always talks about belonging and she
talks about the fact that in our society
especially the Western world you know we
say be confident in yourself you know if
you don't believe in yourself how can
anybody else believe in you and if you
don't love yourself how can anybody love
you but what that unconsciously
dismisses is the need for community and
belonging and maybe it is chicken or the
egg maybe it's not you love yourself and
then I can find a way to love you
maybe it's others around you love you
and it's easier for you to love yourself
and that that belonging that role that
leaders play and study creating an
environment where people feel that they
belong wholly belong is part of the
recipe of getting the most out of people
I'll take anybody step further I don't
know if you there's a New York Times
article about an island that has the
longest life expectancy anywhere in the
world and they credit basically their
generations lived again
yeah and the basic reddit with three
things they credited it with
Mediterranean diet they drank red wine
you know pretty consistently and then
it's the fact that every night all the
people on this island in Europe get
together and they have like well it's
not really a party but just like they
see each other and they go home they go
to sleep they wake up and they do it
again and it's the fact that like the
community has an expectation every night
we're gonna see each other and it leads
to happier life a longer life you know
all this stuff so like you know it
sounds kind of whoo when you say it and
Bieber just like oh yeah whatever
community you know like actually there's
science behind this like this is true
and it's pretty hard to actually you
know to your point like disprove it and
so therefore like it works there's
something to it think about what's going
on with racism classism and it's
fundamentally it comes down to belonging
we call it equality but if I'm not equal
I don't belong and there's such an
opportunity for more belonging so it's
been awesome to connect and talk about
these things and hopefully people who
hear and watch will hear some things
that resonate and that they connect with
and help them feel like they belong or
help others feel like they belong for
sure where where can we send people to
find you or find more about focus the
usuals for me so Twitter tat Cole ATL
LinkedIn Instagram I'm super open and
available on all the things all the
platforms and focus brands focus brands
calm or you can follow all of our brands
Jamba and Moe's and Cinnabon and Auntie
Anne's and McCallister's and
Schlotzsky's and Carville and more
brands to come directly on any of their
social channels okay thank you so much
for your time and a lot dude again
likewise thanks